la belgique en plein burlesque un
premier film très remarqué cette semaine
une drôle de comédie où l'humour est
toujours très proche de la poésie un
humour aussi un peu noir dominique
poncet et jean-bernard hier champion du
monde de cracher de noyau d'abricot et
richard ham luis conseil avec un
cracheur de 14 9 71 m c'est beaucoup
on amuse abricots
c'était des gens très terre à terre qui
ont une seule une seule logique a acquis
il ya énormément dans merde ils leur
tombe dessus des tas d'ennuis de
difficulté ça ne ressemble vachement
regardez là bas juste qu'elle traverse
et en même temps il passe au dessus en
se riant presque de même
benoît poelevoorde ne leur ai pas dit on
l'aurait deviné les convoyeurs attendent
est un film belge est cher je te
présente donc suspicion et pas seulement
parce qu'il a été tourné en belgique par
des comédiens belges
il n'y avait en effet qu'un homme du
plat pays en l'occurrence benoît mariage
pour imaginer ses convoyeurs attendent
l'histoire totalement loufoque d'un
photographe minable qui veut obliger son
fils a gagné le record du monde de
fermetures et d'ouvertures de forme et
tout ça pour quoi
pour gagner une voiture et le slam qui
me sortait avec toi et a pas eu de
soucis d'exotisme au départ et est bon
l'exotisme il vient du regard peut-être
des gens qui connaissent moins bien la
région du film et opt le projet fils
mais il y avait surtout
une tendresse et beaucoup de
bienveillance par rapport à ces
personnes même si on les voit évoluer
souvent dans ces situations pour le
moins incongru ou insolites l'étrier à
la sec sera facturé nonobstant l'état
dans lequel le vêtement sera rapportée
non non c'est en vous dites moi
maintenant de tendre hommage d'imprimer
des mamans patrick il a nonobstant sylla
nonobstant la paix benoît n'a pas fait
dans son film on rit et on pleure on rit
rayman ya des moments où on se dit je ne
sais pas si je dois rire ou pleurer
si l'on vous dit que les convoyeurs
attendent est l'une des plus belles
surprises cinématographiques de la
rentrée surtout surtout croyez le et
courez le voir